hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
throughout his work the confessions
you're going to see saint augustine
making reference over and over again to
the scriptures specifically to the holy
scriptures of christianity and these
include you know jewish writings like
the the law and the prophets and then we
also have later things that are
distinctively christian like for example
paul's letters which augustine is going
to reference and the gospels and other
things as well
and the latin term for this is scriptura
sacra scripture if we're saying holy
scriptures and scriptura really just
means
writings these are things that have been
written down
and transmitted and are part of the
community they're part of what the
christian community focuses on and
guides its conduct and its mind by and
what's really interesting is as we go
from book to book to book
we see that saint augustine develops a
different appreciation
and understanding
for these and you know the ground is
already sort of laid because there are
people in his life who think that these
matter and he
takes them seriously tries to engage
with them finds that at first he can't
get much out of it and then later on
as he learns how to read them how to
make sense of them
he it turns out that the scriptures are
incredibly
rich and deep and diverse
so
why are we focusing on finding wisdom in
the scriptures because the very first
attempt that he has occurring in book
three
takes place right after he has
encountered cicero's hortensius and you
know he finds that cicero is awakening
in him
a desire for wisdom a desire not just to
do philosophy but to use philosophy as a
a way a path to attain wisdom and then
in chapter 5
we see that augustine says i decided to
turn my mind to the holy scriptures and
see what they were like
behold i see something within them that
was neither revealed to the proud nor
made and plain to children that was
lowly on one's entrance but lofty and
further advance and that was veiled over
in mysteries now that's what he's going
to realize later on he's writing this
book from the vantage point of somebody
who has passed through this and notice
what he says at the time
none such as i was at that time could
enter into it nor could i bend my neck
for its passageways when i first turned
to that scripture i did not feel towards
it as i am speaking now
but it seemed to me unworthy of
comparison with the nobility of cicero's
writings he's comparing it to not just a
philosopher but somebody who is also you
know a great rhetorician and you know
somebody that augustine you might say
feels a greater
connection
with and
you know
if you think about
scripture um you know a lot of people
will praise the beauty of the will you
know of the king james version
um uh some of it is you know pretty good
prose and some of it is
not quite so so interesting or you know
so
to the point and and so you know you can
understand these comparisons that he's
drawing augustine is saying i just
couldn't get much out of it at the time
in book five he raises some other
issues that are going to be coming up
again stemming from dealing with the the
scriptures they're not giving him
exactly
what he he wants this is in chapter 11
he says
i didn't think it was possible to defend
the things in your scriptures to which
other people had objected so you know
you read holy scripture um you know
there's a lot of different stuff in
there you might say some of this seems
kind of
dubious some of this seems to be bad
examples you know if we're not supposed
to lie then why was it okay for rahab
the harlot to lie you know who
what kind of god tells abraham to kill
his only son you know there's all sorts
of objections that people can make
and he says sometimes i desire greatly
to discuss individual points with
someone highly trained
in those books and find out what he
thought of them there was this olympics
who'd spoken and depu disputed face to
face against the manikins who had begun
to affect me at carthage he advanced
such passages from the scriptures as
could not easily be
refuted and so you know augustine is
saying ah maybe there's something to
this
i'm just not at at the point where i can
use the scriptures to make sense of
things and then
something happens that opens up his his
mind and his experience and this is um
you know in part uh because of ambrose
this is in book six chapter four
he he goes and starts listening to
ambrose's sermons
and it's quite helpful for him he says i
rejoiced that the ancient scriptures of
the law so that's the first five books
of the the bible and the prophets were
now set before me for reading not with
the i which once looked on them as
absurdities when i argued as if your
saints understood them in this way
whereas in truth they did not thus
understand them so augustine is saying
listen when i first encountered
scripture
either i said well it's not very good or
there's all sorts of difficulties and
contradictions in this
turns out
that not everybody understands those
things that way i think this is
something that still goes on today when
people get into you know atheist
christian disputes or other disputes and
they're like you christians say xyz and
then the christians are like
well no actually that's not what we say
for example you know augustine doesn't
think that the world was created
literally
in six days we're gonna get to that much
later um you know he thinks that these
are periods of time
and you know so so if somebody was going
to come along and say to the average
christian you believe the world was
created in six days they'd be like
that's not actually i mean i understand
that genesis says that that's not how we
understand that and that's been the uh
way of understanding it for a very long
time coming back to this so he says that
um
i was glad when i heard ambrose speaking
in his sermons to the people as though
he most earnestly commended it as a rule
that the letter kills but the spirit
quickens so notice what is this this is
a passage from scripture that is being
used as a hermeneutic a way of
interpretation
for scripture
augustine says that ambrose would draw
aside the veil of mystery and
spiritually lay open things that
interpreted literally so on a literal
level
seemed to teach unsound doctrine
he would say nothing that caused me
difficulty although you would state
things i did as as not yet know to be
true so ambrose is teaching him how to
do a different kind of reading you know
it could be
allegorical reading where one thing is
referring to another it could be moral
reading where we're supposed to like
take the the literal thing and move away
from that and say what is the actual
lesson here
so ambrose is giving him a a better
sense of how to
read the scriptures and augustine
engages
in his own reflection about this that he
tells about us in the net he tells us
about in the next
chapter right
it says from that time forward i
preferred catholic teaching
um he goes on and then he then he says
that um you know i with the scriptures
there's all sorts of things that you
know i came to
believe and i would do this in part by
comparing things so
he starts considering the his own
beliefs the things that he believes in
and he says all right people say that i
shouldn't just
uncritically
buy into
what's being said in scripture but
don't i do that with like all sorts of
things in my life do i like verify
every
single thing
you know he says uh i didn't want to
make a mockery of credulity rash
promises of sure knowledge but
do i actually have that with with most
things he says um i consider how
countless were the things i believed
though i had not seen them nor was i
present when they took place human
history
places and cities i haven't seen even
things about my friends things about
physicians things about countless other
men
unless we believe these things he says
nothing at all could be done in this
life
i thought of how i held with fixed and
unassailable faith i was born of certain
parents
how the hell would i know this i can't
know this unless i believed it by
hearing about them and he says by all
this you persuaded me that not those who
believe in your books
but those who do not believe in them are
the ones to be blamed and not to be
given a hearing if they say to me how do
you know these are the books of the one
true and most truthful god dispensed by
his spirit to the human race and so he
says this truth was to be believed
for no hostile and slanderous questions
many of which i'd read in philosophers
who contradict each other could extort
from me the answer that i would at any
time believe you do not exist right
whatever your nature may be
so augustine is considering his belief
or if we want to use the latin term
crederae the word we get credo creed or
credence
from right we we believe in a whole
bunch of things and you know in his case
he's believing in scripture and
about god and he also says something
else that's kind of important here
why couldn't god just let us figure
these things out on our own you know why
couldn't we just use pure reason
like the philosophers claim to and
actually a lot of the philosophers don't
claim to use just pure complete reason
all by itself
that's you know a sort of a limit case
that philosophers buy into all sorts of
things they put their pants on or their
you know tunic the same way as everybody
else oftentimes not thinking about it
right so he goes on and he says
i always believe that you are and you
have care for us though i did not know
either what must be thought concerning
your substantial being or what way led
up to you
therefore since we were too weak
to find out the truth by pure reason
for that cause we needed the authority
of holy writ i now began to believe
that in no wise would you have given
such surpassing authority throughout the
whole world to that scripture
unless you had some plans for it right
god is giving us scripture
to help us out when we run into problems
with where reason is going
we're not stopping reasoning we're
actually incorporating scripture into it
and he says
unless you wish that both through it you
would be believed in and through it you
would be sought so scripture isn't just
supposed to give us a bunch of
propositions that we then believe in
it's supposed to provide us with the
rudiments of some guidance for
how to approach god how how we ought to
orient
ourselves and he says now that i heard
many things in these writings explained
in a probable
manner i referred the absurdity that
used there to cause me difficulty
to the depths of their mysteries there
there's you know it could be that
there's all sorts of absurdities in
scripture and it doesn't make sense
it also could be that there's something
deeper going on there and that's what
what
augustine is saying he has now
discovered
in book seven there is actually a
chapter which involves
a uh comparison
of um pagan philosophy
with
sacred scriptures right this begins in
in chapter nine
he says
take this idea in the beginning was the
word and the word was with god and the
word was god
first part of the gospel of john right
so the word there this is something that
in greek philosophy
had been referenced a lot because
remember the gospels are in greek
originally right so the logos
and gospel of john you know uh in hey rk
angel ogos right
the logos you know sometimes people want
to make it too easy identification oh
the logos that heraclitus is talking
about is the same logos this is in the
gospel of john
yeah we don't know that right it's the
same as the stoics we're talking about
not exactly right because the logos is
understood differently in in different
we could say frameworks but
there's a lot of overlap there there it
doesn't have to be identity
it can be overlap and so you know the
platonists are
talking about this sort of thing and why
not just stick with platonism then one
of the highest philosophies according to
augustine
well
because the scriptures teach
more
he says that
you know i read about the the
beginning of the gospel of john i read
that the soul of man though it gives
testimony of the light is not itself
this light
okay you might get that out of the
plainness too
but that he came into his own and his
own did not receive him but as many as
received him to them he gave power to be
made the sons of god but with that the
plaintiffs didn't have and that is there
in scripture and then he says again i
read there that the word god was born
not of the flesh nor of blood nor the
will of man nor the will of the flesh
but of
god but i did not read there
that the word was made flesh and dwelt
among us so there's all sorts of things
in scripture
that
don't require us to throw away the
philosophy augustine is saying or
culture but certainly surpass it
certainly teach something
going beyond it and it gives all sorts
of examples there you know you can
reference that chapter to
to think about it
a little bit later in book seven he is
going to talk about
paul specifically and this is quite
interesting you know augustine
references paul quite a bit and he says
that
some of these writings of paul were
seemingly contradictory right
and here we go this is the chapter 21 he
says
it was with the most intense desire i
seized upon the sacred writings of your
spirit and especially the apostle paul
now one of the things that we do know
that's kind of cool from a little bit
later on
um these writings are not all bundled
together in one single bible or even
like you know the book you know the
books of paul right
they're often being circulated as
separate things and augustine is reading
them on their own because somebody comes
in at one point and like picks up a book
he's like hey this is paul right here
one of paul's books
one not all of false books right so a
little bit different way of
understanding the texts and how they fit
together anyway
augustine says those difficult passages
where at one time he seemed to me to
contradict himself right so paul
for augustine back in the early days it
seemed to augustine like paul was
contradicting himself he's saying one
thing here in a letter he's saying
another thing here these don't fit
together
it gets even more problematic
because uh
where the text of his discourse appeared
to be at variance with the testimonies
of the law and the prophets right so
that's another thing um let's say paul
is internally coherent
does paul actually
map on properly to the law which paul
has a lot to say about and the prophets
or maybe even the other gospels
augustine is saying look i
see that there's things that somebody
could take as contradictions
particularly at the literal level
when we read scripture properly
we find when we apply wisdom to
scripture in order to get wisdom out of
scripture we are going to find that
these are not actually contradictory so
he says i saw those pure writings and as
having one
single aspect and i learned to exalt for
joy right and some of the things that
he's saying here are quite nice i made a
beginning whatever truths i'd read in
those other works i found to be uttered
along with the praise of your grace
so whoever sees may not glory as if he
had not received not merely what he sees
but also his very ability to see the the
scriptures themselves are kind of a
divine gift and you know the wisdom that
they convey is not something that we
should be you know super proud of or
lord over other people but view as
something that we have
received it's it's something that we
have to look at in the
right way and you know what are some
examples of this well you know he talks
about
um
paul to uh you know discussing the other
law in our members fighting against the
law of our mind you know there's all
sorts of
fruitful passages and ideas that are
that are coming in here
finally in book eight we should talk
about this famous passage in the garden
you know tola atlega take it up and read
augustine is in the middle of this sort
of crisis
and
he hears a voice saying
pick it up and read and you know
what are we talking about well there's a
book there and it's a book of paul and
he does take it up and read and what
does this lead him to well you know
finding a passage
that is going to help him out and he
actually has an example here somebody
else who
also
takes up and reads and it's a different
passage he's like okay i should become a
monk right and so
what does um augustine read
not in rioting and drunkenness not in
chambering and impurities not in strife
and envying but put you on the lord
jesus christ and make not provision for
the flesh in its concoupa senses and its
desires right and then augustine says no
further wished i to read nor was there
any need to why because it's spoken to
him about the existential problem that
he is struggling with namely that he
wants to be good you know and he wants
to be devoted to god but he also wants
to screw around he likes having sex he's
just said a little bit earlier
you know my prayer is god give me
chastity incontinence but not yet
because i like to i like to you know get
some you could say and
this scripture passage
at the right time
for the right person
for augustine
helps to
make a shift within him and so this is
another important way in which scripture
is providing wisdom wisdom not just you
know in a theoretical sense
wisdom about how to live
and reorient
and you might say fortify
one's own
life so we've come all the way from
man this scripture stuff it's written in
kind of a dumb way and it doesn't make a
hell of a lot of sense all the way to oh
there's so much more here than i could
ever
explore but i get what i need out of it
at the right time when i'm engaging with
it for augustine
you